hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out a brand new RX zero mark 2
that was just announced by Sony has a
one inch sensor it's the same sensor
that is in the rx100 mark 5 which a lot
of us use for vlogging not only will it
now record 4k internally it has a much
more advanced auto focusing especially
this I oughta focus and it also has a
flip up screen I don't care who you are
no one can tell me that this is not
absolutely the cutest thing that you
have ever seen this entire camera is
waterproof up to 30 feet and you guys
can tell right here that this body of it
is made of a very rugged material it's
small its compact which makes it perfect
for traveling it's also so inconspicuous
if one of those things where it's not
intrusive
so you're not carrying around a massive
camera a lot of people get intimidated
especially with the vlogging when you
have this huge camera that you're
carrying around I got a chance to check
this out for the past week so I thought
that I would take it out on a few
adventures I went to visit some Papi's
here in California because you've had so
much rained everything so beautiful
everything is green and the flowers are
blooming everywhere so I took this out
and here's a little bit of footage that
we got from the poppy field
this is my new rx0 we're on our way to
see some puppies and possibly the
poppies may not be there they may be
sleeping they are very picky other times
they want to come out but this is my RX
0 2 blog it looks as though there may be
a lot
[Music]
screen so great like I can see what I'm
doing
please give a linear money there's no
sign anywhere that says how much money
it doesn't but I'm assuming it's ten
dollars because it said on the intranet
how are you I'm good how are you good
thank you all right so it's ten dollars
for parking
Oh
first stop at the poppy field is using
the restroom it took us about an hour to
have to get here so it's quite a long
drive but definitely worth it
[Music]
so Bertie we're trying to figure out
which way to go at all if you get for
the best shot at the testing out the
high frame rate and just taking some
photos this camera is so cute and
perfect for sort of a situation like
this we have found are these ants why do
they have wings
oh-oh I'm disgusted I'm we're moving on
[Music]
the first version did record 4k but not
internally so you needed an external
recorder to be able to record 4k but
this one does record 4k internally so
you don't need anything extra this one
is the original version as you can see
it looks very very similar to the second
version but since this screen does flip
up you can see that it is just slightly
a little bit thicker I'm really excited
because that was really one of the
things that I wish that this camera
originally had I would love to know what
quality do you guys even watch your
videos in because I always talk about
shooting in 4k and a lot of people say I
don't ever even actually watch content
in 4k especially for your in Safari and
you're on YouTube you don't even get the
option to watch 4k it only goes to 1080
which kind of drives me crazy but all
this effort into exporting 4k videos for
you guys and you don't even get to enjoy
the crisp quality also another cool
thing about this new camera is you're
able to transfer 4k footage of this
directly to your phone sony also
announced two new apps if you've been in
a Sony family for a while then you're
probably extremely familiar with a
PlayMemories app which allows you to
transfer videos and footage from your
cameras to your phone but they now have
a new app it's now called the image edge
mobile but it also allows you to do
remote camera on and off which this is
something that I think is awesome
because if you do have your camera
mounted somewhere and you can't actually
reach it so I'm looking at the corner of
my room like if I had it mounted up
there I wouldn't have to reach up and
get it because using bluetooth and if I
did have power going to it like I
wouldn't actually ever have to touch it
I could just use this to be able to
control it so in addition to overhauling
the PlayMemories app which is now the
image edge mobile they now have this
movie at an add-on app which is kind of
awesome because you basically can take
all of those videos that you've just
transferred to your phone and you can
edit them having a very simple image
editor especially something that is
developed by Sony to work with their
cameras and their footage is such a
blessing I can't even get over this
because it's such a simple app the app
is extremely intuitive you just go
through and you can add some of the
so these are all the videos that I
already captured drop those in just like
that and here's your timeline it's super
simple and you can just drag and drop
you can easily change the aspect ratio
right here so if you want to do an
Instagram story so you can go in and
trim and it's so fast click OK
and that's it like that's basically
that's that's everything this camera
also has embody image stabilization
which is pretty impressive like I'm just
watching some of this footage and it all
does look super smooth so I just know if
you're out vlogging and filming at least
your footage will look pretty steady so
let's turn this on I have been using it
for a little bit but you can see here
that flips up so you guys can see
yourself this also has super slow motion
so much like most of Sony's cameras you
may be familiar with the high frame rate
so this can shoot up to 960 or thousand
frames a second which is pretty fast
obviously the higher the frame rate the
decrease in the quality of the content
so usually I just shoot on 60 frames
even though it's not 4k but you can
still slow that down and still have
higher quality video the autofocus on
this is really fast but one of the
things to note is it doesn't have a
continuous autofocus so once you hit
record whatever the set distance is that
it's focused it will stay in that focus
range this does sometimes cause problems
if you are filming yourself and then
you're trying to film something far away
or something super close so to avoid
running into any of those issues
whenever I was out filming and I was
filming myself I would stop recording
flip it around and then grab that focus
and continue filming so it is kind of a
different style when you were used to
just continuously vlogging so I'm
definitely hoping that in the next
version that that is something that they
implement because having the continuous
autofocus really is such a key part of
vlogging it's already hard enough
vlogging and making videos by yourself
and then having to worry about is the
footage is in focus that's where this
flip up screen is super helpful if you
like shooting in picture profiles you
can also do that on here I used to do
that a lot more but when I'm just
shooting stuff like this like they're
not true like doing anything
crazy so I sort of just keep it on like
a normal picture profile nothing too
crazy but if you do love to have more
flexibility when you're color grading
your footage you can use different
picture profiles on here so you can
basically customize this to match any of
your other bigger Sony cameras like your
a7 s your a7s2 Grade seven threes we're
out here testing out the RX zero mark to
obviously the key feature of this is it
does have the flip up screen this is so
awesome because I can actually see
myself in new Jenna this is cool some
photos and some videos
[Music]
here's some pictures wow that's really
good I'm impressed that's that's me
problem as all of this track feature so
if you are shooting something like a
vertical video like this I can put that
on Lindsey right there and I can hit
start and it will automatically track
her she is moving around and you do want
to keep something in frame like this
makes it super simple that if you are
shooting horizontal video and you do
want to post something on Instagram you
can easily track your subject and then
export this and then eat that's it let
me show you guys inside here this is
where you have your SD card your HDMI
out your micro USB and this is also
really exciting because you can use a
microphone input with this so just kind
of silly because rx100 work five it
doesn't even have an audio input that's
something that i've always wanted on
that camera over here this opens up as
well and that's where your battery goes
at your record and your off buttons and
on the bottom is where you can screw in
a tripod or any other mounts and of
course this is waterproof so make sure
that if you do take this in the water
that this stays closed
well do the cool things where this
camera is that it's waterproof now the
last time that I tested out the rx0
iowa's on an exotic vacation in Hawaii
will I'm not on vacation wire right now
but I am at breakfast like do have a
glass of water
nobody put you guys in it okay
even gonna fit I think so
I should drink some displacement
Hawaii vacation just a week this is the
best underwater test it's definitely
better than my sister's she didn't take
her camera into a pool with a waterproof
scooter did she she did this little grip
many of you guys have seen before so you
can plug that right here in the back and
that will allow you to control your
camera so watch this I'm recording now
it has a little recording button right
here you can also zoom zooming in
zooming out this is what it looks like
zoomed all the way in it is nice because
you can zoom while you're recording as
well I also pulled out to a little
tripod oh my gosh it really it's so cute
now I'm gonna leave you guys with some
vlog footage that I filmed from this
over the past few days this is something
that you guys are looking for like a
small portable little camera it's 4k
it's rugged it's waterproof small
compact inconspicuous great onboard
audio also does interval shooting so you
can do really cool time lapses it's just
a super fun addition to my tool can you
guys Los Angeles traffic is no joke like
people
don't know how to drive and the roads
aren't made for this many people like
it's actually shocking that anybody ever
gets around or anywhere on time which
usually they don't I'm on my way to
Lily's girl
[Music]
this is the craziest thing ever
I'm so in shock like this is the
craziest thing ever like there are dogs
and fitness activities all day I've
never seen I've never seen so many dogs
in one place this is insane
and there's like food trucks there's a
porta potty incredible congratulation
[Laughter]
[Music]
overall I think this is a super-fun
Camry only thing that you need to pay
attention to is your focus to make sure
that things are in focus I do love the
flip up screen like the first time that
I saw this I was just in shock I was
like what how did they make this so
small and tiny it's super cool I don't
think that this is a camera for
absolutely everyone but I do think that
if this is something that you're looking
for like this is a really great camera
it shoots 4k it's so inconspicuous that
when I was out vlogging with nobody even
thought place it's just so small that no
one's gonna think that you're recording
high quality content on this but
surprised you are I look forward to
seeing what you guys think of this and
especially the new Sony imaging apps
like I'm so excited about that I do so
much on the go and on my phone on my
iPad that having things like this to
make my workflow easier when I'm on the
go is so exciting
[Applause]
[Music]